if an opportunity presented itself today  and they said  we want to bring you in as the backup  would you take that yeah you'll take  that  if an opportunity i know i have to find  my way back in okay so  yeah if i have to come in as a backup  that's fine  colin kaepernick six years now is it  since he made a big spectacle of himself  and said that america's evil and  disrespected the flag  and was booted from the nfl  and then made a lot more money  selling hatred of america through  sneakers than he ever would have made in  the nfl  colin kaepernick is back  begging begging to be let back into the  nfl he just wants that opportunity and  he's willing to even go through some  hardship for that he knows look he knows  it's really valuable for a person to be  able to play in the nfl this from colin  kaepernick the same man who what a year  or two ago said that playing for the nfl  is like working as a slave on a  plantation in the antebellum south